Donc aujourd'hui on va passer à la considération de la création de l'homme.
Donc il y a deux portions importantes à considérer quand on pense à la création de l'homme.
Il y a l'aspect créationnel lui-même, de quelle manière Dieu a opéré cette création,
quelle est la constitution de l'homme.
Et déjà sur la base tout simplement de la lecture naturelle du texte
et de nous concentrer sur la manière dont Dieu a fait l'homme,
il y a beaucoup déjà des dialogues naturellement établis avec les théories de l'évolution.
Et comme on a fait la dernière fois, on va permettre que les textes nous parlent de manière inflexible sa position.
Et il y a une richesse particulière quand on étudie la doctrine sur l'être humain
et c'est notamment le fait qu'on a été fait à l'image des dieux.
Et donc ça mérite plus de concentration, plus d'attention.
Donc aujourd'hui, on sera très accrochés au texte,
mais les textes vont naturellement nous mettre en dialogue avec les alternatives,
qu'on peut dire théistes, évolutionnistes.
Et on va vouloir plutôt nous concentrer sur l'image des dieux,
ce qui est vraiment la richesse pour nous dans la semaine prochaine.
Donc petit rappel de ce qu'on a considéré jusqu'ici.
Donc on est en train de traiter la position confessionnelle chrétienne historique à propos de la création.
Et donc l'objectif principal pour nous, c'est de nous rappeler que l'interprétation littérale du récit biblique
ou des récits bibliques à propos de la création, à propos de l'origine de toutes les choses,
elle se porte de manière confessionnelle, c'est-à-dire de manière historique,
elle se porte vers l'interprétation littérale des jeunesses.
Donc ça, c'était le plus grand travail de la première grande leçon,
c'est de nous assurer que décroire de manière littérale à Genèse,
c'est une question du christianisme historique confessionnel.
C'est-à-dire que de nous dévier de cette interprétation,
c'est de nous dévier de la reconnaissance historique
de quelle manière la Bible a été interprétée depuis sa rédaction
et au long de toute l'histoire du christianisme de manière prédominante.
Donc c'est très nouveau.
On a aussi des soubires aux pressions externes à la Bible
par des théories qui n'ont même pas des fondements convaincants
et suffisants de la science elle-même
pour changer la manière d'interpréter la Bible
et par là trahir et sacrifier la méthode d'interprétation biblique.
Et avec ça, on est en train de sacrifier,
de manière directe ou indirecte,
l'inspiration, l'autorité, la suffisance et la clarté des Écritures.
Et par là, on est en train aussi de sacrifier plusieurs connexions
entre les doctrines bibliques.
Car par exemple, si nous avons un deuxième Adam,
c'est car on a eu un Adam historique.
Et si on ne traite pas la Genèse de manière historique,
il n'y a pas de salut.
OK ?
Donc, c'est important de considérer que l'interprétation littérale de Genèse
est une question confessionnelle.
La deuxième chose qu'on a considérée,
c'était de considérer en fait quels sont les rapports
entre la Bible et la science de manière générale.
Et donc, pour faire court,
les seuls contrastes ou incohérences ou contradictions
qu'on va retrouver entre la Bible et la science,
c'est à cause du fait que soit
il s'agit d'une interprétation incorrecte des Écritures,
d'un côté, soit il s'agit d'une théorie
qui est prise comme si c'était une loi.
Il n'y a pas de réelles découvertes scientifiques
qui puissent rentrer en conflit
avec ce que la Bible nous enseigne
lorsqu'elle va croiser ses déclarations
avec les questions scientifiques.
Et on a compris aussi
que l'aspect de la considération
de l'origine de toutes les choses
n'est pas exclusive aux religions,
n'est pas exclusive au christianisme.
Les philosophes et les scientifiques
cherchent à découvrir
quelle est l'origine de toutes les choses.
Et donc, nous devons considérer
que la possibilité d'une origine intelligente
est la plus probable,
même par les moyens de l'évaluation
ou de l'observation de la science.
Donc, je ne vais pas revenir sur tous les points,
mais c'est très important pour nous de savoir
qu'il n'y a jamais eu des contradictions
entre la Bible et la création,
car elle est Dieu qui est l'auteur de la Bible.
Elle est Dieu qui est l'auteur aussi de la création.
Et donc, ensuite, on est passé
à considérer
quelle est cette déclaration confessionnelle historique
à propos de la création.
Et donc, on a considéré les premiers paragraphes.
Donc, on va réécrire les premiers paragraphes
de la confession de foi.
Donc, elle nous dit clairement,
« Au commencement, il a plu à Dieu,
Père, Fils et Saint-Esprit,
pour la manifestation de sa gloire
et de son éternelle puissance
et de sa sagesse et de sa bonté
de créer ou de faire en six jours
les mondes et tout ce qui se trouve,
chose visible et invisible,
et tout était très bon. »
Et donc, ici, c'est la déclaration,
les paragraphes.
Nous voyons de manière très claire
que c'est une interprétation littérale des Jeunesses,
la précision très claire en six jours.
Et là, c'est juste un petit rappel
que c'est très nouveau pour nous
la considération
de chercher à considérer la possibilité
d'une terre vieille.
Et les chrétiens, malheureusement,
ne prennent pas conscience
de pour quelles raisons
c'est tellement important et intéressant
pour la théorie de l'évolution
de suggérer une terre si vieille.
C'est tout simplement car ils ne trouvent pas
les évidences suffisantes
pour justifier,
par toutes les données scientifiques,
une réelle connexion entre les espèces
envers une évolution.
Et la seule ressource qu'ils ont,
le seul recours qu'ils ont,
c'est de suggérer que si nous n'avons pas
toutes ces données,
c'est car ces choses ont pris énormément de temps
pour se passer
et nous avons quelques petites traces,
mais nous n'avons pas la possibilité
dans l'enregistrement historique
de la race humaine
d'avoir les données
qui pourraient suggérer ça.
Les problèmes pour nous,
c'est qu'à partir du moment
où on commence à céder
envers la possibilité
d'une terre vieille,
on va rentrer automatiquement
dans plus des complications
par rapport à d'autres aspects bibliques
à propos de la création
comme celui qu'on va voir aujourd'hui.
Car la Bible,
non seulement nous présente
les six jours littéraux,
corroborés à plusieurs reprises
par l'interprétation des dieux les mêmes,
comme on a vu en Exode chapitre 20,
lorsque Dieu va donner la loi,
il va dire que Dieu a tout fait
en six jours,
donc de manière littérale.
Mais même par la considération
de la création de l'homme,
on voit que Dieu a créé l'homme
de manière immédiate,
de manière directe,
à partir d'un élément
très spécifique de la création,
en soufflant directement son esprit,
et ça annule,
comme on verra,
toutes possibilités
dans les écritures scripturaires,
toutes les possibilités
d'une soi-disant possible évolution
d'une espèce à l'autre.
Et donc, pour eux,
le plus intéressant d'avoir
une longue durée,
c'est pour pouvoir justifier
l'évolution entre les espèces.
Et si dès le départ,
on est complètement renfermé
dans l'impossibilité d'une évolution,
il y a encore moins d'intérêt pour nous
de chercher à subir ces pressions
envers les jours longues
ou la terre vieille.
OK ?
Et donc,
quelle est la déclaration confessionnelle ?
Donc, on a considéré
cinq aspects ou cinq vérités.
Donc, la première, c'est
les dieux seuls,
uniques et trinitaires
et l'auteurs de la création.
Donc, qui a créé l'univers ?
Au commencement, Dieu créa.
OK ?
Ensuite,
avec quel but Dieu a créé ?
Ce n'est pas car il y avait
une nécessité en Dieu,
c'est tout simplement
car il n'a plus à Dieu les faire.
Donc, Dieu a créé toutes les choses
avec le but
de révéler sa gloire,
de maximiser la révélation de sa gloire.
C'est-à-dire que non seulement
Dieu a créé toutes les choses
pour révéler sa gloire,
mais Dieu a créé toutes les choses
exactement de la manière
dont il a créé
afin de maximiser
la révélation de sa gloire.
Et donc, question bête,
de quelle manière
une création si longue
qui a besoin d'évoluer
peut maximiser
par rapport
à une création
qu'on appelle
fiat ex nihilo,
à partir de rien,
une création
par déclaration,
une création immédiate.
Qu'est-ce qui va maximiser
davantage
la manifestation
de la sagesse des dieux,
de la puissance des dieux,
etc.
Et donc ici,
dans la confession,
il dit clairement
pour la manifestation
de sa gloire
et de son éternelle puissance
et de sa sagesse
et de sa bonté
des créaux,
des fers,
ainsi jouent les mondes
et tous ceux qui se trouvent.
Donc,
Dieu a créé toutes les choses
pour manifester sa gloire.
Et donc,
les comment,
comment Dieu a créé
toutes les choses,
il a créé des manières
à maximiser
la révélation de sa gloire.
Et donc,
comment,
il y a trois aspects
par rapport
à ces comment.
Donc,
les premiers
qu'on a considérés,
c'était les camps.
Donc,
avec quelle durée,
l'importance
de considérer
l'interprétation littérale
des six jours
de création
comme les moyens
qui maximisent
la gloire des dieux.
Ensuite,
on a considéré
de quelle manière
par rapport
à la création
dans son ensemble.
Et là,
on a fait la défense
de cette déclaration historique
qui va décrire
la création
comme étant
fiat ex nihil.
Fiat
qui veut dire
par parole
ou par décret,
c'est à partir
de sa parole,
de son décret
que tous les atomes
qui sont venus
à l'existence
sont venus
car Dieu les a réclamés.
OK ?
Dieu les a décrétés
par sa parole
et Dieu l'a fait
à partir de rien.
Sans préexistence
de matière,
il les fait
ex nihil.
OK ?
À partir de rien.
C'est à partir
de son propre décret.
Et ensuite,
on a considéré
plusieurs souveretés
liées
à cette création
fiat ex nihilo
et donc
en nous rappelant
que c'est une création
à partir des dieux,
toutefois distincte
des dieux
et complètement
dépendante des dieux
et donc
c'est les dieux
qui permettent
toutes choses
et quelque part
une création
qui est en train
de subsister
dans ces dieux
qui maintient
l'existence
de toutes les choses.
À ces points-là,
ça serait intéressant
de considérer
que pour la plupart
des théologies
systématiques,
donc légèrement
différentes
de nos confessions,
lors de la présentation
des doctrines
trouve
une espèce
de distinction
d'abordage.
Donc,
je viens de vous dire
que Dieu a tout créé
à partir de rien
par son décret
et c'est clair
qu'être humain
il sera placé
comme la couronne
de la création,
la portion la plus importante
de la création
comme on verra aujourd'hui.
Mais,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer aussi
que lorsque Dieu
était en train
de créer
toutes les choses,
il n'était pas
qui est en train
de créer
chacune de ces choses,
mais il était en train
de créer
un système intégré,
un système intégré
qui a des lois,
notamment les lois
qu'on étudie
par la science,
des lois
qui composent
chaque être créé,
mais qui composent
surtout
l'intégration
entre tous
les êtres créés
et entre
toute la création
elle-même.
c'est-à-dire
cet univers,
il est marqué
par plusieurs
systèmes
qu'on appelle
les systèmes
de la providence
de Dieu.
Et donc,
voilà pourquoi
il y a plusieurs
théories systématiques
qui,
avant de considérer
la création
de l'homme,
elles considèrent
ici la doctrine
de la providence.
Nous allons considérer
la doctrine
de la providence
après,
mais elles nous rappellent
que Dieu,
non seulement,
a créé
chaque être,
mais il a créé
les systèmes
qui vont maintenir
l'existence
de ces êtres
et même
ces lois
ne seront pas
en train d'agir
ou d'exister
toutes seules,
mais elles aussi
seront maintenues
par Dieu lui-même.
Donc,
ce n'est pas un Dieu
qui a donné les corps
dans un horloge
et qui a abandonné
l'univers,
c'est un Dieu
qui maintient,
qui gouverne
et qui dirige
les coursus
de l'univers
et notamment
les coursus
de l'histoire
car au centre
de l'univers
et de l'histoire,
bien sûr,
il y a Dieu
mais au centre
de l'histoire
de la création,
il y a l'homme
qui joue quelque part
un rôle principal.
Et donc,
voilà pourquoi
c'est important
de considérer
que même
toute cette préoccupation
des dieux
de créer
toutes ces lois
qui vont maintenir
les fonctionnements
continus
de toute la création,
c'est particulièrement
en pensant
à l'homme.
C'est comme
avant
de recevoir
la naissance
du bébé,
nous prenons
ces neuf mois
pour commencer
à planifier
la vie,
préparer la chambre,
etc.
Et donc,
c'est Dieu
qui a préparé
l'univers
pour l'arrivée
de l'homme.
Et donc,
le cinquième aspect,
notamment,
quand on est en train
de considérer
ces aspects
à propos de la création,
celui qu'on va considérer
aujourd'hui,
on va commencer
c'est que Dieu
a maximisé
particulièrement
la révélation
de sa gloire
dans la création
à travers
la création
de l'être humain
qui a été créée
à son image.
Donc,
c'est la couronne
de la création,
c'est quelque part
l'apothéose
de ces récits
de la création.
Et donc,
bien sûr,
si l'homme
a une importance,
elle ne doit pas
être confondue
avec l'importance
de Dieu lui-même,
car il dérive
de Dieu
son importance
et donc,
bien sûr,
que Dieu reste
l'être
le plus important.
Quelque part,
l'être humain,
il est le centre
de la création,
mais au centre
il a l'image
de Dieu
et Dieu
est le centre
de l'homme.
Et donc,
c'est important
de ne jamais oublier
ces choses
dès le départ.
Et donc,
ce dernier aspect
par rapport
à la création,
donc la création
de l'homme,
est un aspect
qui mérite
une considération
exclusive
et particulière.
Donc,
voilà pourquoi
on va passer
des paragraphes
quand on est en train
de considérer
la confession de foi
et voilà pourquoi
dans la théologie
systématique,
on fait une distinction
entre la doctrine
de la création
et soit une subdivision
pour traiter exclusivement
la création de l'homme
et particulièrement
l'image des dieux
dans l'homme,
soit un chapitre
complètement nouveau
pour traiter ces choses.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
car ça fait partie
encore du comment
des dieux
dans la création.
C'est une partie
inséparable
du quand
et du comment.
Donc,
le fait qu'être humain
soit l'apogée
de la création
fait que ça soit
naturel
qui est
les six jours
soit six jours
littérales,
que ça soit court
car tout ce qu'il y a
en train de faire
c'est pour placer
l'homme
dans l'univers
et inséparable
aussi de l'univers
humain,
de la création
elle-même.
Donc,
cette conception
d'avoir
une distance
énorme
entre toute la création
et l'homme
est complètement
contre-intuitive
et contre
l'intuition
biblique
en plus d'être
contre toute la théologie
biblique.
Et donc,
c'est une partie
inséparable
mais une partie
tellement importante
qui mérite une pose
particulière,
elle mérite son propre
paragraphe dans nos
confessions
mais plus que ça.
Cette doctrine,
elle mérite un paragraphe
exclusif dans les récits
bibliques lui-même.
Donc,
on vient de lire
que la Bible elle-même
dans les récits de la création
elle est en train de
maintenir un rythme
en continu
avec la création
de tous les êtres
de tous les éléments
qui composent la création
mais même dans cette journée
où Dieu a créé
tous les autres animaux
terrestres,
il y a une claire pose,
il y a comme une conférence
trinitaire
et les pluriels divins
apparaissent
et selon la plupart
des interprètes bibliques,
c'est notamment
un pluriel
qui a l'intentionnalité
de nous présenter
devant
une interaction
entre plusieurs personnes.
Donc,
on sait très bien
par la révélation biblique
qu'il s'agit
de la Trinité.
On a d'autres passages
bibliques qui nous montrent
que la Trinité,
chacune des personnes
de la Trinité
a participé
à la création
et que ça fait
complètement
du sens
que nous serons là
devant
un Dieu famille,
un Dieu trinitaire,
un Dieu Père,
Fils et Saint-Esprit
qui vont créer
l'homme
et la femme
son image.
Voilà pourquoi
j'ai ma vance
mais l'homme
et la femme
seront créés
dans un environnement
marital,
familial
afin de pouvoir
représenter
ces aspects
des lettres
des dieux,
divines
de la Trinité.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer,
il y a cette pause,
il y a cette rupture,
il y a un paragraphe
particulier
pour la création
de l'homme
et tout cela
pointe envers
cette apothéose,
ce sommet
qui est l'homme,
la couronne
de la création.
Et donc,
nous devons
nous arrêter
pour considérer
la création
de l'homme
qui malheureusement
dans nos jours
et notamment
à cause
de ces théories
qui à partir
d'une proposition
d'une origine
impersonnelle,
d'une énergie,
des éléments
qui n'y pensent pas,
qui n'ont pas
des sentiments,
des personnalités,
d'une explosion
hasardeuse
et qui pour plus
qu'on veut proposer
que l'origine
était hasardeuse,
on veut quand même
nous convaincre
de manière très incohérente
que tout marche
envers une évolution
et une complexité
sans aucune raison.
Lorsqu'il y a
toute observation
de la réalité
dans son état présent
après la chute,
il y a une loi
qui s'appelle
la loi de l'entropie
observée par la science.
Tout objet
ou toute chose
qui est laissée
exposer au temps
sans mentir
a une tendance
à se détériorer.
Et donc,
même si les lois
scientifiques
prouvent les contraires,
on veut quand même
réclamer
une force
qui nous conduit
ou qui s'est conduit
de manière aveugle
et complètement
contradictoire
envers l'évolution,
envers la complexité.
Donc,
la réalité,
c'est que si nous sommes
devant la génération
la plus dépressive
où nous voyons
comment les personnes
qui ont les plus
embrassé
cette philosophie
du nihilisme
ou du manque
de signification,
la philosophie
post-moderne
qui est couplée
à cette notion
d'une origine
qui n'est pas personnelle,
donc quelque part
clairement justifiée
par la Bible
comme on désire
de se livrer
à ces passions
morales
charnelles,
on veut supprimer
l'origine morale
de toutes les choses,
un créateur
saint et juste,
mais on est au même temps
en train de sacrifier
la signification
de l'être humain.
Et donc,
s'il n'y a pas
de but pour l'existence,
il n'y a même pas
d'explication,
donc même
l'incohérence
d'une nation
comme la France
de se fier
tellement
des droits humains
en oubliant
que les droits humains
ne pourraient pas
exister
si ce n'était pas
l'arrière-plan
chrétien,
judaïque
des racines
occidentaux.
Et pourquoi ?
Car à partir du moment
où on croit
dans une origine
qui n'est pense pas,
qui n'a pas
de personnalité,
de valeur en soi,
il n'y a plus
aucune base
pour défendre
la valeur de la vie.
Et voilà pourquoi
on rentre de plus en plus
dans des dialogues
pour accepter même
certains cas
d'euthanasie
sur la base du fait
que si la vie
n'a pas de signification,
le suicide
devient une option
complètement valable
pour ceux
qui sont en train
de souffrir.
Et donc,
l'une des plus grandes
raisons
de la dépression humaine,
c'est car
nous avons encore
des demandes personnelles
qui doivent être satisfaites,
des demandes relationnelles,
des demandes d'amour,
des demandes morales,
des consciences,
des coupabilités.
Et nous sommes
en train de nous dire
nous sommes
une blague cosmique,
quelque chose
qui est aliénée,
déconnectée
de la réalité originale.
Car si la réalité originale
était une énergie
qu'ils ne pensent pas,
il n'y a pas
de justificatif
pour nos crises existentielles,
pour nos crises morales,
pour nos aspirations,
pour les vertus.
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est que la fin des comptes,
on est en train
de sacrifier la noblesse
de l'être humain
pour maintenir
une origine
qui n'est pas personnelle,
qui n'est pas divine,
qui n'est pas bonne,
qui n'est pas morale.
Et donc,
voilà la crise existentielle
de nos jours.
Et il y a toujours
une connexion
avec cette théorie.
Une chose
est en train
de nourrir l'autre.
Par contre,
il y a beaucoup
d'incohérences
car nous voulons
être des bons citoyens
en cherchant
à réduire
l'être humain
aux fonctionnements sociaux
sans avoir
aucune explication morale,
métaphysique,
pour qu'on soit
des bons citoyens.
Et à la fin des comptes,
nous savons
que nous ne sommes pas
à cause de la corruption
du péché.
Et donc,
nous voilà devant
ces incohérences
et la Bible
avec son explication
littérale
qui est la seule
capable
d'expliquer
l'homme
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui.
L'homme,
il a encore
des aspirations
envers la perfection,
envers la signification
pour la vie,
envers l'éternité.
Et d'où viennent
ces aspirations ?
Elles viennent
de notre origine
à l'image de Dieu
pour ne pas traverser
la mort,
avec une conscience
qui était satisfaite
par un comportement
original
qui était bon
et complètement satisfait
en n'est pas
voulant
se satisfaire
de la création
car on se satisfaisait
du créateur
lui-même
avec la création.
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est que la Bible
explique
les démons
les plus nobles
et profonds
de l'être humain
et la Bible
est la seule
capable aussi
d'expliquer
quels sont les diagnostics
radicals
pour l'être humain.
pourquoi l'être humain
est aujourd'hui
cette incohérence
où d'un côté
il aspire
des choses nobles,
il possède
une conscience morale
mais en même temps
il n'arrive pas
à vivre
à la hauteur
de sa conscience.
Pourquoi il n'est pas
satisfait ?
Pourquoi l'être humain
est
cette incognite,
cette crise
en soi-même
qu'il peut
faire
de la musique,
du poème,
faire des bonnes œuvres,
de la bonne science,
de la bonne médecine
et de l'autre côté
s'exterminer
pour rien,
s'est blessé
tous les temps.
D'où vient
cette prédisposition
humaine
à la corruption,
à la dépravation ?
Et l'explication publique
c'est
nous avons ces aspirations
quand on a été créés
à l'image des dieux
et nous sommes
dans cette condition
car on a échoué,
car on a été privés
de la gloire des dieux.
Et donc c'est
l'essai diagnostique.
Donc les manifestations
mauvaises de l'homme
dans sa vie
et dans la société
n'ont pas pour origine
les restes
de sa nature
animale
d'une évolution
bestiale.
Elle a pour origine
la corruption,
la chute.
Et donc
voilà pourquoi
c'est très important
dans la génération
d'insister
et d'étudier
les récits bibliques
à propos de la création.
Un autre point
en termes de pertinence
qui est très important
de rappeler,
c'est que nous allons
considérer
que l'être humain
a été créé,
l'image des dieux
telle qu'il a été créé
avec toute la richesse
pour plus qu'on considère
que les récits bibliques
soient concis
par rapport
à l'explication
de ce que l'homme est,
sa raison d'être,
les buts de son existence,
sa composition.
La réalité
c'est que c'est
plus que suffisant
et malheureusement
il me semble
que l'église chrétienne
est très mal instruite
par rapport
à la manière
dont elle se comprend
elle-même.
Car à la fin des comptes,
la rédemption,
les saluts,
la sanctification
n'est rien d'autre
que de revenir
à cet état
ou ces cadres créationnels.
C'est-à-dire,
si l'homme
et la femme
ont été créés
à l'image des dieux
dans un cadre marital
étant distinctes
et complémentaires,
les deux faits
à l'image des dieux,
mais homme-homme,
femme-femme,
principe d'autorité
et soumission
dérivés
de l'être divin
lui-même,
soumission est merveilleuse
dans quel sens ?
Dans le sens
où Christ
est pour nous
le sommet
et l'exemple
des soumissions
au Père.
Dieu le Père
est l'autorité,
Dieu le Fils
soumis,
les Saint-Esprits
soumis au Père
et au Fils.
Et quand on considère
la création
de l'être humain,
on va voir
de manière très belle
qu'est cette interaction.
La soumission
n'est pas une conception
telle qu'on l'a
aujourd'hui
tordue
et corrompue,
abusive quelque part.
Non,
c'est de voir
comment le Christ
a du plaisir
à exercer
cette soumission
envers Dieu
et comment l'Église
va représenter
ce que la femme
devrait être
dans sa soumission
à Christ
envers un leadership
masculin
et biblique.
Donc,
la mission
est commune
sauf que
pour l'accomplir,
on a besoin
l'un et l'autre,
chacun occupant
sa fonction.
Elle en tant qu'aide,
lui en tant que
celui qui dirige,
qui va conduire.
Donc,
là aussi,
on va remarquer
que lorsqu'il Paul
va parler du fait
qu'on doit être
rempli du Saint-Esprit,
c'est-à-dire
automatiquement
sanctification,
tous les principes
présentés
sont des principes
de soumission.
Soyez remplis,
ne vous inéverez pas
du vent,
mais soyez remplis
du Saint-Esprit
en vous soumettant
les uns aux autres.
Quelle est l'expression
de notre retour
à la création de jeunesse ?
C'est de nous exercer,
l'homme,
dans cette soumission
directe à Dieu
et à Christ,
bien sûr,
et la femme,
au mari
et à Christ,
bien sûr,
l'Église à Christ.
Et dans la société,
ces mêmes principes
vont s'appliquer.
Les serviteurs
envers leurs patrons,
les enfants
envers leurs parents,
et tout cela
est l'explication
de l'apôtre Paul
de quelle manière
nous sommes en train
d'être restaurés
à l'image
des dieux
dans toutes les sphères
telles
que nous retrouvons
dès le départ
ici en jeunesse.
On a été créés
pour gouverner
l'univers,
l'homme dans sa position,
la femme comme son aide.
Et à partir de là,
on a été appelés aussi
à faire de la culture,
donc faire les villes,
cultiver,
peupler la terre
et donc établir
les réseaux sociaux,
la culture
et à partir de là,
faire l'imitation
des dieux
en tant que gouverneur
de la terre.
Et donc chacun de nous
dans notre position.
Voilà pourquoi
c'est très important
et c'est aussi
l'une des explications
de la plus grande tristesse
qui traverse
notre génération.
Car depuis la révolution sexuelle,
on a tellement
renversé les rôles
et même l'Église
semble avoir été
impactée
par ces principes.
Et là,
il faut qu'on se rappelle
que dès le départ,
la création originale,
c'est les sommets
duquel on a chuté
et la rédemption,
c'est un retour
envers cette même
configuration.
Et c'est à partir de là
que nous allons
retrouver la joie.
Car étant créé
par Dieu,
c'est en suivant
son ordre
que nous allons
retrouver
la satisfaction
de notre existence.
Et donc,
des doutés de ça,
c'est des marchés
à large pas
envers l'autodestruction.
Et donc,
nous allons lire
ces deuxièmes paragraphes
de manière introductoire
aujourd'hui.
après avoir fait
toutes les autres créatures,
Dieu créa l'homme.
Il les créa
mâles et femelles
avec des âmes
raisonnables
et immortelles
qui les rendaient
propres
à cette vie
avec Dieu
pour laquelle
ils avaient été créés.
Donc,
c'est très important
de voir déjà
les remarques.
Après avoir fait
toutes les choses,
toutes les autres créatures,
Dieu créa l'homme.
OK ?
Et donc,
sommet,
aboutissement,
après l'homme,
c'est fini la création
et donc là,
on est vraiment
dans l'apogée.
Il est créé
à mâles et femelles.
Donc là,
on reconnaît
la constitution
de l'être humain
qui a été créée
à l'image de Dieu.
Donc,
l'humanité
à l'image de Dieu
composée par
hommes et femmes
avec des âmes
raisonnables
et immortelles.
et donc là,
ce sont déjà
quelques indices
de l'image
de Dieu
dans l'homme
et dans le fait
que même si
on a eu
un point de départ,
OK ?
On a eu un point de départ
dans l'histoire,
donc on n'est pas
pré-existant,
OK ?
On a eu un point de départ.
Par contre,
on n'aura pas de fin.
On a été créé
de manière
immortelle
qui les rendait
propres
à cette vie
avec Dieu.
Donc,
les buts
de l'existence
de l'homme
ici suggéraient
donc on devrait
être des représentants
des dieux
dans la création
et à partir de là,
Dieu nous a constitués
d'une manière,
bien sûr,
à son image
pour qu'on puisse
être son représentant
dans la création.
Donc,
à propre
à cette vie
avec Dieu
pour laquelle
ils avaient été créés,
ils ont été faits
à l'image des dieux
en connaissance,
justice
et vraie sainteté
ayant la loi
des dieux
inscrite
dans leur cœur
et les pouvoirs
de l'accomplir.
Donc,
à partir de là,
c'est la condition
ou la position
originale
de l'homme
dans sa perfection
morale
originale.
Ils avaient
cependant
la possibilité
de la transgresser
puisqu'ils étaient
laissés
à la liberté
de leur propre volonté
qui était capable
des changements.
Donc,
ici,
c'est vraiment
très important.
Nous sommes devant
les mêmes réformateurs,
la même tradition réformée
de la confession
de Westminster,
baptiste des fois
qu'il y a la nôtre,
d'autres confessions
réformées,
les mêmes
qui vont insister
sur le fait
qu'il n'y a pas
de libre arbitre
après la chute.
OK ?
Les libres arbitres,
il a existé
et c'était
qu'il y a dans les jardins
des dents
au moment de la création
avant la chute
qu'il a existé.
Donc,
voilà pourquoi
l'une des explications
de la possibilité
des chutes
passe par
un test
où l'homme
ou à l'homme
a été conçu
une opportunité
de volontairement
se soumettre
à tout ce qu'il connaissait
comme bon,
comme bien.
Et donc,
il était complètement
qualifié
à son stade
pour savoir
que son choix
est le mieux possible,
le plus juste
et voilà pourquoi
certains veulent mettre
en question
si Adam
était les bons
représentants.
Donc,
on peut être sûr
qu'il était les bons
représentants
car,
différent de nous tous,
il n'était pas
corrompu
dans sa volition,
dans sa volonté
ni dans ses jugements
moraux.
Il a été tenté
et par sa concoupescence,
il est parti
vers les péchés.
Donc,
toute sa faute
est de sa responsabilité.
Mais il était
le mieux représentant
de notre race
déjà
car il était
créé
parfaitement moral.
Et donc,
ce n'est pas un choix.
Une consolation,
c'est que si vous ne voulez
pas avoir Adam
pour représentant,
on ne peut pas
avoir les Christ
non plus
par les mêmes principes.
Car Dieu
nous traite
de manière
fédérale
comme représenté
par Christ
car un jour
dans les premiers
Adam,
on avait été
représenté
par la chute.
Et donc,
c'est important
de considérer,
on va revenir
lorsqu'on va considérer
la chute,
mais pour l'instant,
c'est important
de nous rappeler
que les libres arbitres
ici présentés,
c'était
la capacité
d'arbitrer
librement.
Pourquoi aujourd'hui
on n'a pas
les libres arbitres ?
On a la libre agence,
on agit
selon nos propres choix,
nous faisons nos choix
de manière volontaire
et nous faisons nos choix
avant la rédemption
et les saluts,
nous faisons nos choix
toujours contre Dieu,
toujours pour nous enfouir
de la présence
des dieux.
Et pourquoi ?
Car même si on a
la liberté d'agence
et la libre volonté
et nous serons
redévables devant Dieu
à cause
de nos choix
volontaires,
la réalité,
c'est que dans
notre condition
des chutes,
des pécheurs,
des transgressions,
des contaminés,
nous sommes privés
de la gloire des dieux.
Donc tous nos choix
sont nécessairement
contaminés par la chair,
par les péchés.
Et nous avons
un penchant
envers les péchés,
un penchant contraire
à la direction des dieux
après la chute.
Donc,
par exemple,
pour illustrer,
s'il y a une faute
dans un match
de foot,
l'arbitre,
il peut siffler
de manière objective
les faits,
par contre,
il y aura
une division
dans les supporters.
Moitié
de l'estade
va dire
qu'il avait raison,
l'autre moitié
va dire
qu'il avait tort.
Et pourquoi ?
Car
les jugements
moraux
de l'être humain
sont contaminés
par la corruption
idolâtre
de sa volonté.
Et c'est ça
la condition
de l'être humain
aujourd'hui.
Et donc aujourd'hui,
on ne pourrait pas
choisir pour Dieu,
pour ceux
qui glorifient Dieu.
Tous nos choix
sont contaminés
par la chair.
Et là,
particulièrement
la position
des non-croyants.
Une fois régénérée,
c'est ce qu'on appelle
une restauration partielle
du libre-arbitre
qui a encore
les restes
de la chair
mais qui a
une volonté
prédominante
habilité
pour faire
la volonté
des dieux.
Le problème,
c'est qu'Adam,
il n'avait pas
se penché
envers la corruption.
Sa capacité
d'arbitrer
était parfaitement
en cohérence
avec la loi
des dieux,
la loi morale
des dieux
qui était inscrite
dans son cœur
et bien sûr,
davantage avec
cette parole
qui a été déclarée
externe envers lui
de ne pas manger
de fruits.
Donc là,
Adam,
il a eu
la possibilité
de se soumettre
volontairement
à Dieu.
Et donc,
il était,
Dieu a laissé
la liberté
de leur propre volonté
qui était capable
des changements.
et donc,
c'est à partir
de là
qu'il y a
par son mauvais
choix,
usage
de son libre-arbitre,
Adam va
pécher.
Et donc,
à partir de là,
il va perdre
cette capacité
d'arbitrer
sans l'influence
de péché.
Les paragraphes 3,
en plus de la loi
inscrite dans
leur cœur,
ils ont reçu
l'ordre de ne pas
manger de l'arbre
de la connaissance
du bien et du mal.
Tant qu'ils ont gardé
ces commandements,
ils ont été heureux
dans leur communion
avec Dieu
et ont dominé
sur les créatures.
Et donc,
pendant les temps
qu'ils n'avaient pas
péché,
ils ont pu
réjouir
de ce qu'on appelle
la béatitude
originale.
Donc,
on peut penser
à chaque viration
de jour,
Dieu qui venait
les visiter.
On peut penser
à chaque sabbat
ou chaque samedi
où c'était
les jours
des communions
intenses
avec les seigneurs.
Donc,
la facilité
de faire
toutes les choses
qui Dieu
les avait ordonnées
de faire.
La femme,
avant la chute,
n'avait pas
des douleurs
d'accouchement,
n'aiderait pas
avoir des douleurs
d'accouchement.
Elle ne voudrait pas
prendre la position
des directions
de son mari,
comme on verra plus tard.
Lui,
il n'était pas abusif
dans son leadership.
Il avait
la responsabilité
primaire
de pouvoir
protéger
et diriger
la famille
pour la nourrir
spirituellement.
Et donc,
il pouvait,
l'homme avec l'aide
de sa femme
et la femme
avec l'homme,
en aide de l'homme,
il pouvait
exercer parfaitement
ce qu'il devrait faire
et recevoir
les sourires
des dieux
dans leur rencontre.
Et donc,
voilà la manière
dont la confession
nous présente
de manière résumée
les principales vérités.
Donc,
aujourd'hui,
c'est plutôt
introductoire
et je propose
qu'on vienne
vers les textes
bibliques
pour faire
une première lecture
et quelques remarques.
Donc,
on revient
sur
les versets 24.
Et donc,
il y a déjà,
dès le départ,
ces rythmes
créationnels.
Il y a eu
un soir et un matin,
chaque jour,
la création en continu,
tous les éléments là.
Et là,
Dieu commence
à peupler la terre
verset 24,
que la terre
produise
des animaux vivants
selon leur espèce,
du bétail,
pardon,
des reptiles,
des animaux terrestres.
Rémarquez bien,
selon leur espèce,
donc répétition
des expressions
qui rendent
possible l'évolution,
ok ?
Chaque animal
selon son espèce.
Et cela fut ainsi.
Dieu fit les animaux
de la terre
selon leur espèce,
les bétails
selon son espèce
et tous les reptiles
de la terre
selon leur espèce.
Et Dieu vit
que cela a été bon.
Donc,
à nouveau,
évaluation
de la part des dieux,
un constat,
tout était bon
a aussi
la signification
que tout était parfait.
Donc,
la seule explication
pour
même la mort
ou les déficiences
que nous avons retrouvées
même dans la création
hors-hommes,
donc,
Paul,
dans l'être roman,
va nous expliquer,
chapitre 8,
que la création
est en train
de souffrir
car elle est devenue
otage
de ceux
qui devraient
la protéger
plutôt,
ce qui était
la tâche
de l'être humain.
Et donc,
tous les malheurs
qui traverseraient
la terre
sont liés
à la corruption
de son responsable
fédéral,
de son roi.
OK ?
Comme dans tout royaume,
les mauvaises décisions
d'un roi
vont engager
nécessairement
leur patrie,
leur nation
de la même manière
et leur peuple
de la même manière.
C'est comme ça
que se passe
la position d'Adam
en tant qu'il roi
représentant des dieux.
Et donc,
à partir de là,
tout était bon,
donc,
tous ces êtres créés
selon leur espèce
étaient parfaits.
Par contre,
on va arrêter
avec cette histoire
d'espèce,
selon son espèce.
Et c'est très important
car la Bible
va élever
la conception
d'espèce
et bien sûr
que l'homme
ne peut pas être créé
selon l'espèce
des dieux
car Dieu ne peut pas
produire des clones
car immédiatement,
à partir du moment
où Dieu crée,
si c'est possible
d'être Dieu,
de créer un dieu,
c'est soi-disant
Dieu ne serait pas Dieu
car il serait déjà
une créature
par définition.
Et donc,
Dieu ne peut pas
se reproduire.
Dieu subsiste
en trois personnes
éternellement
et Dieu ne peut pas
créer d'autres dieux.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant,
nous sommes
infiniment
au-dessus
de toute autre créature
car on n'est pas
créé selon
l'espèce
d'une créature,
mais nous sommes
créés
à l'image
des dieux.
Paul,
il va
simplifier
les langages
quand il prêche
aux Athéniens,
en Athènes,
et il va dire
« étant race
des dieux ».
Donc,
c'est très intéressant.
C'est comme
s'il voulait
renforcer
cette comparaison
entre espèce
selon espèce
et nous,
race des dieux,
c'est-à-dire
génération
des dieux.
Car nous
pouvons remarquer
de manière très claire
une distinction
infinie
entre
tous les animaux
et Dieu lui-même.
Et donc,
c'est très intéressant
car c'est un peu drôle
qu'on veut suggérer
qu'on soit en train
d'évoluer
à partir des singes
car quelque part
les singes,
quand on pense
à l'aspect mécanique,
on a l'impression
qu'ils sont très proches
de nous.
Et bien sûr
que la science
et la biologie
vont prouver
le contraire
car il y a
des sauts infinis
même en termes biologiques
entre les singes
et l'être humain.
Mais c'est clair
que même si Dieu
nous a permis
de voir un animal
qui puisse être similaire
dans quelques aspects,
dans l'apparence externe
au moins,
la réalité,
c'est que nous
pouvons distinguer
une distinction
infinie
entre nous
et les singes
quand même.
Et donc c'est pour dire
pour plus
qu'on ait été fait
dans cet univers
avec quelques éléments
composants
de cette création,
c'est clair
que ce que Dieu
a fait dans l'homme
est infiniment
supérieur
et les sauts
ne peuvent pas
être expliqués
tout simplement
car c'est l'un
des trous
ou des vides
les plus importants
contre la théorie
de l'évolution,
c'est que pour plus
qu'ils auraient pu
expliquer
une espèce
d'évolution
physiologique
ou biologique,
ils ne pourraient
jamais
expliquer
l'origine
de l'âme,
ce qui fait
de l'homme
l'image
des dieux,
la source
de la personnalité,
des émotions,
de la complexité
émotionnelle
plutôt,
de la complexité
des langages,
de l'autoconscience
un être
qui est infiniment
distante
de tous les autres
êtres
qui ont été
créés.
Et donc,
la seule explication
est celle-ci,
Dieu qui s'arrête,
un Dieu
trinitaire
et qui dans
ses conseils
sublimes
de la Trinité
avec l'engagement
et la participation
des trois
par une déclaration
à nouveau,
faisons l'homme
à notre image,
c'est notre
rassemblance.
Et donc,
de quelle manière
il sera ici
évoqué
comme image
de rassemblance,
on va juste
faire quelques remarques
à propos de ces points.
Donc,
la première chose
à remarquer,
c'est que nous sommes
devant quelque chose
d'especial
qui a été créé,
c'est une création
issue
d'un conseil
divan,
quelque chose
qui a rompu
avec les rythmes
du chapitre,
du chapitre 1.
Donc,
les trois personnes
de la Trinité,
Dieu le Père,
Dieu le Fils
et Dieu le Saint-Esprit,
qui sont en train
de créer quelque chose
à l'image
de cette sainte
relation entre
trinitaire éternelle.
La béatitude suprême,
c'est la joie
à trouver
dans cette relation.
Donc,
c'est quelque chose
de profondément
relationnel.
Et donc,
l'homme sera placé
dans cette création
en ayant
tout cet environnement
autour de lui
comme un moyen,
attention,
d'identifier
l'intelligence
des dieux
dans l'univers,
d'identifier
la bonté
des dieux,
la sagesse
l'amour
des dieux
dans cet univers,
mais en même temps,
en ayant la capacité
d'avoir un rapport
envers cet univers
créé,
en étant
représentant
des dieux.
Et donc,
c'est un moyen
des révélations
des dieux,
d'une part,
et lui-même
étant les moyens
des révélations
des dieux
les plus importants
dans son interaction
envers cet univers.
Ça aura
une implication
quand on considérera
où se place,
où se trouve
l'image des dieux
dans l'homme,
car certains vont suggérer
que c'est qui
est dans la portion
immatérielle,
mais pour que l'homme
exerce une fonction
des représentants
des dieux
dans l'environnement,
dans la sphère
où Dieu nous a placés,
les corps
ont quelque chose
d'important
C'est un
qui Dieu
nous a donné
et qui nous a rendu
capables
de faire usage
de ces corps
dans son interaction
avec ces mondes
pour dans cette relation
fonctionner
comme un petit dieu,
comme un représentant
des dieux
dans ces mondes.
Et donc c'est très risqué
de vouloir disséquer
dans quelle portion
de l'homme
se trouve l'image
des dieux
même si on peut
reconnaître
que certaines portions
de l'homme
peuvent être
plus intuitivement
rapportées
à l'image des dieux.
Donc là,
c'est important,
Dieu a fait quelque chose
comme les sommets
de la création,
quelque chose
de spécial.
Ensuite,
donc c'est quelque chose
de spécial,
ensuite c'est
les faits
qui,
ici déclarer
que l'homme
a été fait
selon l'image
des dieux
ou comme je vous ai dit
la race des dieux
pour être
son représentant.
Image
a une idée
des copies
des représentations,
rassemblances
a une idée
plutôt d'expression
légèrement
sous gestion
des fonctions.
Il sera
similaire à Dieu
et il fonctionnera
de manière
similaire à Dieu
en termes
de relations
semblables
et en termes
de fonctions.
Donc ensuite,
on est informé
aussi
à propos
de la constitution
de l'homme.
Plus tard,
au chapitre 2,
lorsque Dieu
va décrire
de quelle manière
il a formé l'homme,
au verset 7,
on va retrouver
que l'éternel
Dieu
forma l'homme
de la poussière
de la terre.
Il souffla
dans ses narines
en souffle de vie
et l'homme
dévant
un être vivant.
Et donc ici déjà,
on commence à retrouver
quelques impossibilités
de dialogue
avec la théorie
de l'évolution.
Donc,
on n'a pas été formé
à partir
des autres êtres,
on a été formé
de cette poussière
cosmique.
Je vous ai déjà présenté
les termes hébraïques
originales.
C'est la moindre particule
qui était présente.
Ce n'est pas de la boue,
c'est la moindre particule
qui était présente
dans la terre.
Et nous pouvons,
par la science,
constater que ces éléments
qui composent
de manière atomique même,
cette poussière
de la terre,
l'être humain,
sont des éléments
qui ne pouvons qu'y retrouver
dans la planète Terre.
Tous les éléments
dont on a besoin
pour former l'homme.
Et donc,
c'est important
de reconnaître
cette réalité glorieuse.
donc,
on n'a pas été formé
à partir
des autres êtres
ni à partir
de la terre
comme de la boue
qui aurait pu
évoluer
envers un être humain.
On a été créé
directement
de cette poussière
de la terre.
Mais cela
ne suffit pas
pour rendre
l'homme existant.
Donc,
jusque-là,
on a été formé
ou modelé.
mais c'était nécessaire
que Dieu
directement soit
le responsable
pour nous créer.
Donc,
remarquez bien
combien
rétrograde
est la suggestion
révolutionniste.
Déjà,
notre noblesse
trouve sa plus grande richesse
sur le fait
que Dieu nous a créés
directement
en tant que son image
en tant que sa race
quelque part.
Et de l'autre côté,
le fait qu'il nous a créés
de manière directe.
Donc,
pas en faisant
usage d'autres êtres.
Et en plus,
on voit de manière
très claire
que par ces mouvements,
Dieu devrait encore
souffler directement
quelque chose
en nous
qui va nous animer,
qui va nous rendre vivants.
Donc,
ce qui nous montre
que l'origine
de l'existence humaine
est directement
liée à Dieu
et l'origine,
ce qui justifie
d'un côté,
la noblesse
et de l'autre côté,
notre soumission
à Dieu.
Et de l'autre côté,
on voit de manière
très claire
que la substance même
de l'homme,
c'est en lui
que nous avons
les mouvements
et l'être,
notre existence.
Et donc,
les facultés
qui nous rendent
image des dieux,
distinctes
de tout autre être
aux créations,
comme on était
en train de parler
par rapport aux singes,
n'est pas un saut
qui soit possible
d'une espèce
à l'autre.
car c'est Dieu
directement
qui l'a originé
par les souffles
de notre esprit
pour faire de nous
âmes vivantes
et c'est ça
qui maintient
cette réalité
en nous.
C'est ces souffles
originels
et c'est cette subsistance
dans l'être de Dieu.
Voilà pourquoi il y a
quelques passages
où Dieu va
quelque part
suspendre
les fonctionnements
raisonnables
des Nabucodonosor.
Il va commencer
à fonctionner
comme un animal.
On va par là
que c'est Dieu
par sa providence
qui soutient
quelque part
cette portion
spirituelle
ou cette portion
immatérielle
que nous avons
et qui a été
soufflée
dans la race humaine.
Et donc là,
on voit
de manière très claire
que la constitution
de l'être humain
était faite
de la poussière
quelque part
de la terre
couplée
au souffle
de la vie
de son esprit
directement
dans nos narines.
Ensuite,
on voit aussi
quelle est la position
de l'homme.
Si on revient
verset 26,
il dit
directement
qu'il soit
notre image
selon notre rassemblance
et directement
qu'il domine
sur les poissons
de la mer,
les oiseaux du ciel,
les bétails,
sur toute la terre,
donc non seulement
les animaux
mais aussi
sur toute la terre
et sur tous les reptiles
qui rampent
sur la terre.
Donc,
il n'y a pas eu
des airs,
l'âge de feu,
l'âge des glaces
et d'imaginer
de quelle manière
on a développé
nos capacités
de gouverner.
Dès le départ,
Adam avait cette capacité
bien sûr
qui en termes
on va dire
des micro-évolutions
scientifiques,
techniques
ont toujours eu lieu
mais c'est incroyable
de constater même aujourd'hui
qu'on croit
si nous sommes avec la Bible
depuis qu'on a
des enregistrements historiques
c'est vraiment
très proche,
c'est là où on a
l'origine de la race humaine.
On n'a pas eu
des pré-histoire,
on a eu
de l'histoire
tout simplement.
Et donc,
l'histoire
elle preuve
que nous pouvons
évoluer
sur les épaules
des géants
qui sont venus
avant nous
mais c'est extraordinaire
de remarquer
les signes
d'intelligence
et on voit
plutôt une involution
de l'usage
de nos capacités
à plusieurs égards
même si
on peut
continuer
d'évoluer
sur les contributions
et on progresse.
Et donc ça c'est très important
de remarquer
quand on regarde
l'histoire
à plusieurs égards
dans plusieurs sphères
des connaissances.
Et donc notamment
nous sommes ici
devant
un être
qui avait été créé
dès le départ
pour dominer
sur la terre
sur les animaux
et avoir
cette capacité.
Et donc tout de suite
Dieu l'envoie
va envoyer
Adam
pour commencer
à faire de la science
à commencer
à nommer
les animaux,
à cultiver la terre
etc.
Mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer ici
tout comme Dieu
a eu ses rapports
envers toute la création
pour créer
il confie
cette création
à l'homme
pour récréer
pour cultiver
et pour fonctionner
comme un petit roi
qui va dominer
dans les sens
où il va gouverner
pour les biens
pour l'épanouissement.
Donc c'est important
de remarquer
Dieu a créé l'homme
et ensuite
il l'a placé
au jardin
des dents
et par la manière
dont Dieu a placé
Adam
au jardin
des dents
il a
lui-même
Dieu
cultivé
ces jardins
comme un paramètre
et un motif
comme un sanctuaire
qui devrait servir
des bases
pour Adam
pour continuer
de reproduire
ces modèles
les modèles des dieux
dans toute civilisation
qu'il allait faire.
Donc ici
nous sommes devant
les liaisons
entre l'image
des dieux
et les faits
qu'il était là
pour dominer.
Et donc
Dieu
créa l'homme
à son image
une déclaration
explicite et ouverte
il les créa
à l'image des dieux
homme et femme.
Donc nous allons voir
plus tard
les implications
et l'importance
comme je vous ai fait
signe au départ
de savoir
reconnaître
égalité
des valeurs
en tant qu'image
des dieux
chacun
de ces composants
de l'humanité
l'homme et la femme
possèdent
l'image des dieux
mais ils ont
ensemble
une capacité
un potentiel
encore plus fort
par les mariages
et par l'accomplissement
à travers
le mariage
pour multiplier
gouverner la terre
et pour servir
des bases même
la cellule fondamentale
et basique
pour toute la société
donc voilà pourquoi
les principes
des masculinités
et féminité
bibliques
doivent s'appliquer
aussi dans la société
c'est pas quelque chose
d'exclusif
au foyer
ni qu'est exclusif
à l'église
et malheureusement
aujourd'hui aussi
on est complètement
en dehors
de toute l'histoire
du christianisme
dans
2000 ans
on n'a pas eu
cette inversion
de valeur
des femmes
qui sont exposées
aux positions
des leaderships
de manière très lâche
de la part des hommes
en ayant des femmes
pasteures etc
donc ce sont des choses
très importantes
à nous rappeler
qui sont ancrées
dans la création
et donc c'est très important
pour nous
de voir
de quelle manière
bon
les femmes
ont beaucoup souffert
dans la société
en abandonnant
les cadres originales
et les respects
envers leur propre nature
et bien sûr
historiquement
c'était aussi
une réaction
des générations
et générations
d'abus
des hommes
qui étaient très machistes
et qui n'ont pas
dirigé la société
comme il fallait
ou la maison
mais qui ont plutôt
dominé
ce sont les fruits
de la chute
comme on va
dès le départ
mais en tout cas
ici c'est important
de nous rappeler
donc hommes et femmes
égaux
en valeur
et en même temps
complémentaires
pour accomplir
ses buts
dans sa plénitude
l'homme et la femme
donc image des dieux
et donc
ils ont été créés
avec cette constitution
et cette identité
sexuelle
si on peut dire
comme ça
la position
donc c'était
qui est à l'inverse
de la suggestion
de l'évolution
donc c'est impossible
de suggérer
évolution
si l'homme
a été créé
au sommet
selon les principes
bibliques
il n'y a pas eu
d'évolution
à partir
de la création
de l'homme
il a été créé
bon
tout était
très bon
c'est la déclaration
des dieux
à la fin
et malheureusement
l'être humain
il sera
en chute
et non
en ascendance
selon la
selon la théorie
l'évolution
et donc
que l'homme
soit fait
de la poussière
de la terre
détermine déjà
le fait
que l'évolution
ne peut pas
dialoguer
avec ses passages
bibliques
le fait
qu'il a été
créé au sommet
non plus
et la claire
distinction
entre l'être humain
et les animaux
et bon
d'autres observations
à faire
c'est que
la race humaine
est une seule
donc une autre chose
que nous ne pouvons pas
dialoguer
avec la
la théorie
de l'évolution
et
de toute manière
la théorie
de l'unité
de la race
pour nous
c'est une certitude
mais
scientifiquement
est
la plus difficile
à être confronté
donc quand on étudie
la migration
des peuples
quand on étudie
l'origine des langues
des variétés
même des langues
quand on étudie
la sociologie
ou l'anthropologie
c'est que
les similarités
qu'on retrouve
entre les hommes
malgré leurs différences
géographiques
malgré leurs traditions
on va voir
infiniment
beaucoup plus
en commun
qu'est
différence
et donc
les traditions communes
ce sont très intéressantes
aussi comme argument
scientifique
car
c'est
le travail
des anthropologues
ils constatent
qu'il y a
dans plusieurs cultures
une notion commune
des déluges
des shoots
et donc
plusieurs autres
aspects
qui démontrent
l'unité de la race
et particulièrement
aussi
les découvertes récentes
des types sanguins
pas très récents
mais de toute manière
comme quoi
tous les types sanguins
peuvent être issus
dans le même couple
c'est qui est le cas
selon la Bible
donc l'unité de la race
elle est déclarée
par la Bible
une seule race
qui devrait donner fond
et
faites des efforts aussi
dans la société
dans vos échanges
si vous voulez parler
des pays d'origine
ou des ethnies
n'utilisez pas
pour distinguer
les êtres humains
entre races
il y a une seule race
ok
et c'est très important
d'être catégorique
à cet égard
et donc
la sixième observation
c'est de considérer
que l'être humain
a été constitué
voilà
des
d'une
on va dire
constitution
dichotomique
trichotomique
il y a deux positions
par rapport à ça
mais la réalité
c'est que la Bible
nous présente
et je vais faire court
pour vous
mais
ici nous avons
une portion
matérielle de l'homme
et une portion
spirituelle
s'il a
qu'il est corps
c'est pas encore
un être existant
donc Dieu
l'a modelé
l'a formé
mais ensuite
il a dû siffler
pour qu'on soit
devant
un être humain
et donc l'être humain
il est inséparable
on sait très bien
que sa portion
spirituelle
va rester vivante
en attendant
la restauration
du corps
et tous seront
ressuscités
corporellement
soit les chrétiens
soit les non-chrétiens
les chrétiens
avec un corps
qui sera
glorifié
pour être adapté
à la réjouissance
pleine
de la gloire céleste
les réprobres
seront
ressuscités
pour être
capables
de payer
ce qu'ils doivent
payer
avec la pleine justice
des dieux
par rapport
à tout péché
qu'ils ont commis
donc un ayant
un corps
qui sera capable
de supporter
cette mesure
infinie
de la justice
des dieux
qu'ils ont mérité
par leur transgression
donc les réprobres
vont aussi être
ressuscités
avec un corps
indestructible
mais qui sera capable
de subir et souffrir
toute la punition
qu'ils méritent
cette même punition
que les chrétiens
souffrent à la croix
à notre place
et donc c'est important
de considérer
que les corps
tels qu'ils ont créés
par Dieu
pas les corps
mais l'être humain
tel qu'ils ont créés
par Dieu
il a une constitution
inséparable
composée d'une portion
immatérielle
et d'une portion
matérielle
par contre
c'est très important
de remarquer
que selon l'enseignement
biblique
on a plein
des passages
et des indices
que même si
l'esprit
et l'âme
sont synonymes
dans la plupart
des textes bibliques
corps et âme
pardon
esprit et âme
l'esprit et l'âme
sont synonymes
dans la plupart
des textes bibliques
c'est intéressant
quand même de remarquer
qu'il y a plusieurs passages
bibliques
qui nous pointent
envers une possible
distinction
des compréhensions
entre l'esprit
et les corps
donc lorsque la Bible
nous décrit
comme mort
spirituellement
l'esprit
doit être perçu
comme cette portion
qui nous connecte
à Dieu
et donc c'est
par la régénération
que notre esprit
est vivifié
et donc
la gouvernance
de l'ensemble
de notre être
c'est
car il me semble
et je suis
avec Lloyd Jones
dans cette position
que l'esprit
c'est le siège
principal
à partir duquel
on arrive
à gouverner
l'ensemble
mais parfois
il est synonyme
du cœur
de l'âme
et il ne faut pas
être très
fermé
à cet égard
mais c'est juste
important de remarquer
que la Bible
nous dit
que lorsque
les non-chrétiens
ne se convertissent pas
c'est car ils ne comprennent pas
les choses des dieux
car les choses des dieux
sont discernées
spirituellement
donc il y a plein de passages
qui nous donnent
l'impression
d'avoir cette légère distinction
entre âme
et esprit
donc l'âme
c'est le siège
des affections
du raisonnement
de l'intellect
l'âme
est quelque part
le siège
de la personnalité
et donc
même après la chute
l'image des dieux
n'est pas complètement
perdue dans les êtres humains
il y a quelques restes
de l'image des dieux
car l'âme
reste là
et cet impact
cette interaction
entre l'âme
et les corps
inséparables
est aussi présente
sauf que
pour être né
pour dieux
il faut que
nous soyons
des esprits
vivifiés
que nous soyons
nés spirituellement
et donc là
c'est une remarque
importante à faire
pour mieux
nous comprendre
et je pense
qu'en termes
d'observation
générale
la seule chose
qui manque
c'est l'origine
de la portion
matérielle
l'origine
de l'âme
car on sait très bien
d'où vient
le corps
mais ça a été
toujours une question
dans l'histoire
de la théologie
de savoir
d'où vient l'âme
et donc bien sûr
tout ça a beaucoup
d'implication
car on prend
les passages
par exemple
des Melchizedek
où Abraham
nous est présenté
comme si
les vies
qui viendraient
des générations
futures
d'Abraham
étaient déjà
dans les sangs
d'Abraham
en faisant
la dîme
à Melchizedek
donc on ne sait pas
de quelle manière
on doit interpréter ça
littéral ou non
mais les deux positions
principales
présentent des avantages
et des difficultés
donc la difficulté
par exemple
de ceux
qui veulent suggérer
que chaque âme
est créée
directement par Dieu
c'est car on sait très bien
que les sièges
et la corruption
du péché
est l'âme
la chair
est dans l'âme
et si Dieu
est en train
de créer
directement une âme
il est en train
de produire
les péchés
de manière directe
et donc
il y a aussi
des difficultés
par rapport
à l'autre position
mais voilà
je ne veux pas
être très fermé
je pense que c'est
un mystère pour nous
l'origine des âmes
il y en a certains
aussi qui présentent
une troisième théorie
c'est la préexistence
éternelle de l'âme
mais cette relation
entre les péchés
d'Adam
et les péchés
de ses âmes
préexistantes
c'est aussi
quelque chose
de compliqué
et ça aura
des impacts
aussi par rapport
à la transmission
du péché
et même
l'incarnation
du Christ
donc
il vaut mieux
rester avec
les mystères
en sachant
qu'il y a
ces deux
positions principales
soit
une génération
directe
des âmes
soit
ce qu'on appelle
les traditionnismes
c'est à dire
on a hérité
quelque part
l'âme
de chaque individu
une portion
du père
de la mère
et de cette manière
on sera
reproduit
et bon
c'est un mystère
pour nous
et nous allons
nous arrêter ici
pour aujourd'hui
donc voilà
quelques remarques
d'observation générale
par rapport à la création
la constitution
de l'homme
et la semaine prochaine
on va se pencher plus
sur l'image
des dieux dans l'homme
donc qui peut prie pour nous
pour conclure
et la semaine prochaine
on va se pencher plus
d'avoir regardé la
la semaine prochaine